hello everybody and welcome to let's
play dead space okay we just unlocked a
room of Secrets got lots of ammo lots of
ammo and a schematic which means that I
should open every one of those which
means hey it's dead get that get that no
no no oh no oh no 2000 credits that guy
was rich I guess tougher enemy federal
oh hello somehow one of them found a way
down to catch his nest
IMATS contain it in a damage escape pod
okay listing executive lockdown now I
found the deck logs okay whatever is
happening around here the came from the
planet when they cracked it open
okay aliens it spread to the colony and
reach the ship Isaac this isn't an
infection it's some form of being in
like yeah I got that conclusion to play
ten seconds ago we've got bigger
problems ship engines are offline on our
orbit is decaying of course get over to
the engineering deck ASAP while I stay
here and figure out what the problem is
of course send me to solve your problems
at least I'm going to the engineering
deck I should be right at home right
I should be perfectly comfortable in my
own environment okay line Rex better
luck Oh to the line gun duh I'm an idiot
okay way too many of those oh yeah get
rid of all of us
um Paul Strauss I need to use up my
pulse rounds I don't have a line gun so
I'm a soda
and got 50,000 credits I'm gonna buy a
couple of pounds what one no no no no
okay three that should be enough to open
any door I see and I can upgrade my
stuff
win-win they're just throwing money at
me I gotta be really early in the game
in this just throwing money at okay what
do we got here wait a minute whoa wait a
minute there are bodies here there were
body bags everywhere I just did there's
still the worms their worms ill get out
here yeah here get out Oh get out of
here
something ate the bodies I don't know
anyone on the show no okay we're good
yeah winner winner oh yeah I'm the best
chapter 2 - completed what I like to
save yeah all right you know what I'm
only gonna save like during these
transitions cuz now that's a bad idea
that is like the worst idea I've ever
had stupid stupid
I'm gonna save occasionally okay course
correction Chapter three how many
chapters are in this game a No
Oh bring it oh I don't you got two
problems I'm working on Boris I'm here
first there's no fuel the engines
seconds at gravity centrifuge is spline
which means there's a couple of trillion
tons of rock pulling it down I need you
to get that centrifuge operational
refuel the main engine and fire it up so
I can stabilize the ship solve it Wow
why do I have to do all your work
God what a whiny God but I'm the hero
subdue it whatever so I'm gonna jump out
of me uh who are you
well trust analog acting chief engineer
Jacob temple uh-huh it's been two days
since they pulled that planet wait what
oh I skipped it ah can I get back to it
when I get back to it you're like darn
it I find it hard to believe that they
assume I ran out of fuel yep some
someone sabotaged it that's all what
happened okay can I get two how do I get
two there's got to be like logs or
something
doesn't there doesn't there have to be
like logs how can I get - oh let me
cycle through how do I cycle through ah
how do I cycle through control ah I
don't know I I don't know I don't know
okay sorry about skipping that guys I'm
trying not to skip those because I mean
I want to know what the story is all
about so well whatever okay locker good
locker
gimme store I don't need you okay bring
it on
oh this looks dark and dastardly who's
out there who wants some
who wants some who wants it okay what
the hell is going on here neighbors okay
he's crazy
pulling his own teeth out yeah your son
forgot a fake mark against gosh unknown
man why would he do something like that
I don't something happened to the audio
log I missed again
cuz I can't see anything
all right don't know what's going on
around here ships been attacked first
the captain dies now we get attacked oh
man
yes get out of here okay all right
upgrade are gone or maybe maybe I should
upgrade you know my rig for something
rig um
I can't get any upgrades darn it all
right not that what can I get you I can
get air Wow
I'm not doing that Jesus range only that
I can get nothing why do I have to start
off with getting nothing
yeah I can get a whole lot of nothing so
I'm not gonna get anything all right
nope looking up great just gonna use
these things for oh yeah
Mele that's what I wanted to do just
gonna use these four doors
I don't trust boom I'll trust anything
laying on the ground anymore what ooh
what's that emergency supplies this
seems like an emergency just saying all
right stomp whose aah hi baby hi oh oh
right in front of me right in front of
my bullet
dead heard that baby go baby go gimme
haha nope oh there's a little thing
fo realz already is
perfect glad I got the assault rifle off
finally cuz those things are sure
alright I'm getting lots of items plenty
to offload how much I got okay I've got
um wait this is where I was high Oh get
off of him I know he's dead no but oh
not another one I'm gonna take care of
this I'm gonna be proactive
let me proactive proactive hahaha
can I don't know scoffs Thunder [ __ ] out
of huge
I stunt the [ __ ] out of them oh that's
another reason for this gun it stops
guys in their tracks oh okay the sulfur
rifle is good okay I'm finding many
reasons that is good that I got the
assault rifle okay yeah go me good first
purchase I don't want these other guns
do though very small ones don't need an
air can I've got almost too much plasma
I can I can upload one then I want to
get the flamethrower but I'm worried
that it's gonna be another useless
because I don't imagine a flamethrower
has a lot of stopping power anyway I got
the money I'm gonna buy another one now
I'm gonna save my money I'm not gonna
waste it on that stuff okay where am I
going
why did I come back in a circle oh
there's no clock I don't know I don't
know why is the music so dramatic right
now
okay glad you got that crescendo out of
the way oh what's this
hold down so straight oh that's how
that's all it took to refuel really oh
good thing I got this boy
I trust you though
get out of here guys sorry no room for
two okay um how do I get that other real
okay
that's a big something
all right moving into the dark abyss
always good always good to go into the
dark abyss oh no no the by me
oh hey I see you get to I am oh right in
your face
hey hey hey I see up oh no you don't
know you don't
nope nope nope
get out of here I got you dead
hi ha ha ha what a bunch of wimps oh
you're not dead that trick don't work on
me anymore hey I hear another one are ya
buddy
come on out and play I got a present for
you are you over there no no don't trust
you give me your item okay
all right wait was that another one is
that why does that sound like an item
what is that why they're all these
strange noises oh hello power node oh
yeah
load me up money love money it sounds
like a monster it really does someone
expects you home tomorrow yeah that's
not gonna happen
best thing it's fisheye yeah that's
right run away get out of here
yeah it's best if like no one ever find
this ship ever again if this ship the
Ripper okay
oh hello fold-down yeah that's good
whatever you did it's working either
every field the schedule reading it's
only a quarter full but that's enough to
store that wants to bring the engines
online
hold on
I saw something you probably did might
want to check that out god you're gonna
die haha what what Oh baby's tired
get out of here dead okay you're bad
goods to sell good get no no no no
come on shoot off the tentacles oh I'm
gonna stop the [ __ ] out of you just
taste my boot [ __ ] yeah ah yeah
yummy you let me get off of me what the
hell oh man I'm tearing up my throat ah
God I'm probably overloading the mic -
jeez don't latch on to my face I need to
use one of my med kits Oh Oh what who's
out there
I'll trust you more off with your head
other than tentacles worms
grody so it's like some alien parasite
that takes over human bodies with worms
ah what oh so sad I'm running away [ __ ]
and yeah
that sounds bigger bring it on
yeah that's what I thought
you know one on a dish I'm so tough oh
oh give me dad
place it med kid I just use and this
game wouldn't be too bad on hard uh get
I don't trust you sorry buddy I'll trust
you
this game wouldn't be so bad on hard I
mean I've hardly gotten damaged well I
guess it is early in the game I'll
probably much more damage later on no
trust you okay I've got a lot of power
nose I I probably should use them for
something oh boy oh holy hell um
actually I have to pause the video here
sorry for going over um thank you guys
so much for watching
as always I appreciate every single one
of you so thank you for watching and I
will see you in the next part bye-bye